[Music]
alright guys let's be honest here at the
score you sports we love nothing more
than rewatching our favorite most
legendary eSports plays of all time
again the first base is attorneys gonna
hit the ground there's cold but what
about us regular gamers oh that was whoa
that's that's a cold zero jump shot
that's literally this I mean be honest
with me have you ever had a clutch in
csgo that made you feel like you want a
major or have you ever pulled off a bear
and steel that you think is worthy of a
score eSports storia video well then
this is the list for you these are the
plays that make you wish mom was filming
when you pulled them off these are the
top ten plays in eSports that make you
feel like a badass
[Music]
starting this off is one of the most
badass ways to destroy your opponent
ripping through them like you were Darth
Vader himself
I'm talking about two three or even four
stocking your opponent in a smash game
think about it you show up to a
tournament hoping to squeak out a win
but wait you know you're better than
that
there's no settling for Less so you
eviscerate your opponent while keeping
all of your stocks talk about getting
smashed the picture champ is above us
here oh oh man silent well we've seen a
lot of force nuts on this stage before
but 35 seconds so we'll fight it down to
his last stop is he gonna get it before
minute passes whoa let's see he's right
to the edge
oh my god
that was emphatic that was amazing
[Music]
number 9 on our list is the moment when
the hunter catches her prey I see you
you can run but you can't hide
look we all know siege has its fair
share of cool and well honestly broken
operators but when that one person on
your team locks in kuvira you know
there's only one thing on their mind
let's go alive you want us getting shot
from the side by still alive he's a
second
you wanna get someone more through the
wall Oh God
now calves is one of the sneakiest
operators in the game but pulling off an
interrogation isn't exactly easy so when
she does catch you alone not only will
she kill you in the most gruesome way
possible but also reveal the rest of
your team when you pull off a calves
interrogation it's nothing short of
badass this is the weirdest spot they're
never going
[Music]
oh my [ __ ] god
three integrations let's go guys the to
interrogation oh that is the best cover
around I've had in my life our number
eight entry is one of the more
groundbreaking things you can do in
overwatch literally we're talking about
Reinhardt and those nutty nutty earth
shatters you see overwatch is a game
where your whole team needs to be
working together in order to get that W
and this is especially true at the
highest level but in soloqueue when that
mercy on your team is just so low
healing their duo and your den G is
jumping around getting shot in the face
well all bets are off
sometimes you just have to take matters
into your own hands and the play that
makes everyone on your team know just
how badass you are
if you've ever played csgo then there's
a good chance you've either tried our
number seven entry or at least you've
been on the receiving end of it how did
this draw this they knew exactly where
they wanted to go the best positions
whoops device for the door to drain
tacos face and the weakest ones I have
to show that's still gonna be a headshot
though it's gonna be seven no Guardian
its body again how many times against
rails on the door I'm talking about
killing someone through mid doors on
dust to hell even I pulled this one off
guys I'm silver - and daddy's here okay
that's not true I never but nailing some
will do mid doors is one of the most
badass things you can do in csgo and
there is nothing more satisfying than
being that guy to force up when everyone
tells you not to
and landing this shot Oh what the hell
head set to OFF Henry's gone simply put
there are no other ways to describe our
number six entry other than all aim no
brain since Valerie exploded into the
eSports world there have been some
pretty insane clips coming our way but
nothing in that game is more badass than
a jet flying around the map and
terrorizing the enemy team with her alt
now don't get me wrong jet is probably
the worst agent at high-level play she
offers little to nothing to a team but
in the off chance you are one of those
monsters who picks jet you better be
doing something like this
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a couple of ways to be a
badass in League of Legends but there's
only one play that makes the number 5
spot on our list in a do-or-die scenario
there's one play that can swing the
momentum of a game snatching Baron from
your opponents out of nowhere is the
be-all and end-all of badass plays on
the rift there's five of them and one of
you they are knocking down the Baron but
wait you have balls of steel so you jump
in and commit absolute larceny and get
out unscathed come on what's more badass
than that TransCanada's on his way as
the manager trying to save this year for
TSM this is going close
coming in at number four is rocket
leagues most heroic play the zero second
goal oh that's a decent touch though
hold on fire whoa
he thought it are you kidding me now
rocket League is one of the eSports most
like traditional sports and in most
traditional sports buzzer-beaters and ot
winners are the plays that blow the roof
off of a stadium
and rocket league is no different
scoring before the clock hits zero is
one thing but having this skill and the
patience to keep the ball in play and
scoring with zero seconds left to clutch
it out well that's a play only a real
badass can pull off
[Applause]
[Applause]
one bullet one kill there are very few
players who had the precision let alone
the cojones to pull off the number three
play on our list so if you thought
maintaining an aka spray in csgo was
hard try styling on your enemy with a
crisp clean lock that would make
screaming proud Oh Oh show me a sex face
Jesus does anyone look the a.k has
thirty bullets for you to unload it to
see tease but obviously style points
matter more when we're talking about
badassery yeah he's got one but it's the
one bullet just something nice on
purpose scream makes me scream oh my god
it's so disgusting our runner-up entry
is a dota 2 players wet dream and no
we're not talking about the TI prize
pool we're talking about absolutely
destroying the enemy team with a no-look
sunstrike as the double kill we'll find
a third mystery he tries to go for the
target try
in Volkers sunstrike is a global spell
that can hit any spot on the map but
that doesn't mean you can always see
what you're aiming at fog of war keeps
the Sun strike fair but real badasses
know that you don't need to see your
opponent to kill them
Jupe jagged that he knows that the Sun
strike might come strike is up he's
watching we hi bet and just waiting for
huh
[Music]
taking the number one spot on our list
is the single most badass feeling thing
you can do in fighting games the magic
pixel come back here we go he has him in
the red potential perfect here yep I
think he's gonna get it oh he's thought
no nobody dropped in there you
definitely want an extra tempt you
wonder the carp is unable to get it put
a big demon uppercut in the follow-up
yeah looking towards the wall as well
all but just shorts but then he killed
me picture this you're concerned your
health is down to a pixel that you can't
even see anymore
and the hit will kill you your opponent
is laughing and they think they have you
dead to rights but you dig deep channel
your inner John wick and explode on them
unleashing combos mix ups and punishes
that they never saw coming
it's party time and the chickens invited
oh why did you say that look I wanna
sleep party oh let's go I call me
overseeing and look at the
oh my goodness
whoa oh my ladies go the [ __ ] bags and
once they're dead you've completed the
reverse perfect on just a sliver of
health and walk away from the setup as a
true undisputed badass all right guys
that was it for the top 10 plays that
make you feel like a badass now if
you're actually a badass head over to
twitch.tv slash the score esports hit
the follow button and turn notifications
on because we are live streaming on the
regular these days and if you haven't
subscribed to this YouTube channel yet
what are you waiting for let's go okay
continuing with the backdrop set tour
okay what is this this is a piece of
basically found footage I mean I can't
describe this to you if you love Locke
if you love so bad it's good if you love
cult films this is a real one you got to
check out my hammock connection